What's up cinema fans?
Do you think you know everything there is
to know about the weird and wonderful world
of movies?
Do you like testing that knowledge and bragging
to your friends about it?
Well then, you're going to love this video!
Welcome to the latest edition of Screen Rant's
Ultimate Movie Quiz.
If you can get all 10 of these questions right,
then you can consider yourself a serious movie
buff!
Keep your score as you go and then leave it
in the comment section below!
Make sure you tell the truth though!
Let’s get started!
Spectre
In the 2015 James Bond movie Spectre, Christoph
Waltz played the villain Franz Oberhauser
- also known as Ernst Stavro Blofeld - but
which actor was originally approached for
the role?
A - William FichtnerB - Gary OldmanC - Mark
Strong
Versatile English actor Gary Oldman was approached
first for the role of Oberhauser in Spectre,
but he wasn't willing to commit to six months
of worldwide production, so the role ultimately
went to the more than capable Christoph Waltz.
Suicide Squad
Jared Leto put everything into his role as
The Joker for Suicide Squad, even though he
didn't end up getting much screen time.
But how did he go about perfecting the character's
laugh?A - He tried different laughs in public
to see which one made people more uncomfortableB
- He subjected himself to tickling in order
to laugh in a completely uninhibited wayC
- He listened to the laughs of every single
previous version of the villain for hours
on end(Screen lights up A)That's right, to
try and find the perfect laugh for his version
of the Clown Prince of Gotham City, Jared
Leto publicly experimented with different
laughs in New York City and Toronto to see
which ones made the people around him look
and feel the most uncomfortable.
Jurassic World
Every high-profile Hollywood movie is given
a secret identity during the early stages
of filming, in order to keep it a secret for
as long as possible, but what was the working
title of Jurassic World?
A - Tropical CycloneB - Debris FlowC - Ebb
Tide
Jurassic World actually shot under the secret
working production title Ebb Tide.
It was chosen by Steven Spielberg long before
director Colin Trevorrow was involved.
No one on set had a clue why Spielberg chose
this name.
Jason Bourne
2016 saw the return to the big screen of Matt
Damon's Jason Bourne - and the movie included
a memorable car chase in Las Vegas, Nevada.
But how many cars were destroyed when filming
the scene in question?
A - 17B - 117C - 170
The Las Vegas car chase sequence - which took
five weeks to shoot - ended up with no less
than 170 cars being wrecked.
This figure is according to producer Frank
Marshall, who knew the number immediately
when questioned, as he had to pay the bills
for them all.
He went onto say that all 170 cars are now
"in a trash heap somewhere".
Sausage Party
At a glance, Sausage Party might look like
a kid-friendly animated feature, but it's
far from being suitable for youngsters.
However, the trailer for Seth Rogen's adult
flick was accidentally played at a showing
of which of the following movies?
A - Kung Fu Panda 3B - The Jungle BookC - Finding
Dory
Yeah, erm...
The red band trailer for Sausage Party was
shown by mistake in a screening of Finding
Dory at Brenden Concord theatre in Concord,
California.
While some youngsters will undoubtedly have
found the whole thing very amusing, others
were left in shock, and their parents were
obviously horrified.
The Martian
In Ridley Scott's The Martian, there are scenes
set in both NASA's HQ and the Chinese space
centre.
However, the buildings that represented those
two places in the movie were actually in the
same city in reality.
Which city was that?
A - BudapestB - BucharestC - Brussels
The buildings that represented the NASA HQ
and the Chinese space centre in The Martian
are actually in Budapest's two most famous
cultural hubs and they're only 3 tram stops
from each other in real life.
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice marked
the first occasion on which Ben Affleck would
portray the Dark Knight on the big screen.
But what advice did the previous Batman, Christian
Bale, offer Affleck about playing the character?
A - "Never break character on set"B - "Make
sure you can piss in that suit"C - "Do NOT
watch the 1960's Batman TV show"
When the pair inadvertently met in a costume
shop when they were each buying a Batman costume
for their kids, Ben Affleck asked Christian
Bale for any advice he could give about playing
Batman.
Bale quite candidly replied by telling Affleck
to "make sure you can piss in that suit" - which
we're sure was very helpful.
Captain America: Civil War
A number of drafts were written for Captain
America: Civil War before the final script
was perfected.
But which of these superhero characters wasn't
even originally written to appear in costume?
A - Spider-ManB - Black PantherC - Hawkeye
It was Black Panther AKA T'Challa who had
a much smaller role in the earlier drafts
and didn't even appear in costume, as the
writers intended to focus on Spider-Man and
save Black Panther's origin for his own movie.
However, when it looked like Marvel wouldn't
be allowed to use Spidey, T'Challa's role
was beefed-up significantly and the studio
stuck with that plan.
Zootopia
The brilliant animated feature Zootopia has
been one of the most successful movies of
2016 so far, but which earlier Walt Disney
Animation Studios movie hinted towards the
movie by showing a poster for it in the background?
A - Wreck-It RalphB - Big Hero 6C - Frozen
Yup, there was indeed a poster for Zootopia
in Walt Disney Animation Studios' 2014 superhero
offering Big Hero 6, and it could be seen
in the scene when Baymax and Hiro fly under
the train tracks.
X-Men: Apocalypse
X-Men: Apocalypse featured the younger generation
of X-Men actors and, as such, Sir Patrick
Stewart's Professor Xavier did not appear.
But which character did Stewart jokingly say
he'd be willing to play in an emergency?
A - WolverineB - ApocalypseC - Mystique
(Screen lights up C)The wonderful Patrick
Stewart jokingly informed director Bryan Singer
that he would be willing to play Mystique
in X-Men: Apocalypse if Jennifer Lawrence
started "playing up", saying "I am so ready
to be naked, painted blue, and the world is
ready for it too."
Thanks for watching and for taking part in
our latest behind the scenes movie facts quiz.
Did you enjoy this video?
How well did you do with the questions?
Leave your score in the comment section below
and don’t forget to subscribe to our channel
for more fun videos like this one!